we did a poll on our YouTube channel and
Incredibly more than 50 000 of you voted
the question was if you were advising
Ron DeSantis would you suggest that he
take the high road when it comes to
Trump's attacks or should he go for the
jugular and immediately begin ridiculing
Trump
seventy percent of you said that
DeSantis needs to go for the jugular
that's absolutely the right strategy if
DeSantis tries to take the high road it
is going to be very very bad for him and
very good for Donald Trump particularly
if there's a ton of candidates when the
more candidates you include in polls the
better it is for Trump if in addition to
that you have DeSantis unwilling to
really face Trump head on I know it's
stupid I know it just signals the idiocy
of the electorate that votes for these
folks but it's going to be very bad for
Rhonda Sanders